so the United States Marine Corps has
grip strength data going back to the
Revolutionary War
they administered grip strength tests at
tons Tavern when they commissioned the
Marine Corps so it literally goes all
the way back to to the very beginning so
they have the ultimate longitudinal data
set grip strength among men today is 30
what it was 50 years ago
not me though I got good grip hell yeah
it turns out grip strength is one of the
best proxies physical proxies for
testosterone levels wow so the Marine
Corps won't even let you go to recruit
training anymore unless you show up for
a year of physical training to prevent
training deaths that's how bad it is so
the handshake the handshake test that's
real it's a legit thing it's a legit
thing it's plastic I've heard that
hanging is some of the best things you
can do for a person like hang from a
tree branch and just well that's what
the Marine Corps has you do if you have
weep grips just hang